it was on monday that eunice first
became a named storm and by the time she
arrived she'd more than lived up to it
approaching the uk the storm underwent
what meteorologists call explosive
cyclogenesis a sudden drop in pressure
generating very high winds by around
lunchtime here on the isle of wight
eunice set a new provisional wind speed
record for england a gust of 122 miles
an hour
was this and other extreme gusts caused
by a so-called sting jet phenomenon
where rapidly cooling air further
accelerates winds that was key to
intensifying storms like the great storm
of 1987. there are features in today's
satellite images like these fingers of
cloud that meteorologists think could
indicate that might have occurred but
it'll take more analysis to be sure
however meteorologists say the winds
were strong enough to justify the
warnings given
even three days ago before the storm
even started to form we knew there was
going to be a strong storm approaching
the uk
red warnings were issued
you know this flooding hasn't come to
pass but there's certainly been some
damaging
and very dangerous winds
and if it hadn't been forecast or if
people hadn't taken the warning
seriously i think you know there's every
expectation that you know
the danger to people would have been a
lot worse the first of two red risk to
life warnings for eunice was for the
south west thankfully the timings of
high tide high winds and low pressure
didn't coincide to cause major flooding
there was a storm surge look at the tide
gauge data for newport in south wales
predicted tides in red recorded sea
level in blue nearly two meters higher
but not high enough to over top sea
walls but the winds were severe enough
eunice still a damaging and deadly storm
as she moved into the second red zone of
london and the south east and caused
further disruption as she made her way
north
now eunice is an intense storm and much
has been said about whether climate
change is a contributor to that but
climate scientists say there's no
evidence so far winds have become
stronger or storms more frequent as the
uk has warmed but storm surges and
floods from heavy rain are predicted to
worsen with climate change eunice spared
us the worst of those but that doesn't
mean we'll be so lucky next time